programming throwdown episode number three erlang take it away jason hey how's it going so we're in a we're in a live setting today which is different usually this is over Skype but today we're here playing some board games hanging out over at my place so we decided to use the Omni mic which looks awesome. Yeah does it looks pretty cool makes you feel like a real radio personality right? Yeah yeah in Mars in the future future martian radio yeah i'm still convinced that patrick bought this at a pawn shop in the future nice all right well you got any news for us um so uh probably one of the biggest things that has come out is the iso standard on c++ uh came out was it March 28th and this kind of finalizes what's been C++
Programming Throwdown 第三期，Erlang。Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好。今天我们在一个现场环境录制，这和平时不太一样，平时我们都是通过 Skype 录制的。但今天我们聚在一起玩桌游，在我家闲聊，所以我们决定用 Omni 麦克风，看起来很棒。是啊，看起来确实很酷，让你感觉像个真正的电台主持人，对吧？没错，在未来的火星电台。我依然坚信 Patrick 是在未来的当铺里买的这个。不错，好了，你有什么新闻要告诉我们吗？嗯，大概最大的新闻就是 C++ 的 ISO 标准发布了，是在 3 月 28 日，这基本上确定了 C++
OX which is now C++ 2011 and has a bunch of different additions you know we talked a little bit about C earlier and you know we might do show on C++ later on and one of the biggest things is this adds a lot of kind of the features of higher level languages, like some memory management. So it has an auto pointer and a shared pointer and really has a lot of awesome features that will make C++ programming a lot easier. I mean, C++ right now still, you know, dominates most of the industrial software world. So something like this is big news. Yeah, unfortunately, I guess they missed their deadline with the OX thing,
OX，也就是现在的 C++ 2011，它增加了很多不同的特性。你知道我们之前聊过一点 C 语言，以后我们可能会做一期关于 C++ 的节目。其中最重要的一点是，它增加了很多高级语言的特性，比如内存管理。它有了 auto 指针和 shared 指针，确实有很多很棒的特性，会让 C++ 编程变得容易得多。我的意思是，C++ 目前仍然主导着大部分工业软件领域。所以这样的消息是大新闻。是的，不幸的是，我猜他们错过了 OX 的截止日期，
and now they have to call it O11? Yeah, that's right. X was not just a one character, I guess. It was actually two. But yeah, I mean, that's a big deal. So it'll probably take a few years before it starts working its way into the mainstream compilers and stuff. Yeah, so it's already in, I think, that's a big deal. So it'll probably take a few years before it starts working its way into the mainstream compilers and stuff. Yeah.
现在他们不得不把它叫作 O11？是的，没错。我猜 X 不仅仅是一个字符，实际上是两个。但确实，这是一件大事。所以它可能需要几年时间才能开始进入主流编译器之类的工具中。是的，所以我认为它已经在里面了，我想这是一件大事。所以它可能需要几年时间才能开始进入主流编译器之类的工具中。是的。
So it's already in, I think, GCC and the latest version of Visual Studio. Okay. But, yeah, by the time, you know, other, you know, by the time those actually become adopted by corporations, I mean, there are some companies that are still using GCC 2.9, you know. Yeah. Or Visual Studio 2005. Yeah, that's right so by the time you know people move on to using GCC was it 4.5 I think is the one with C++ 2011 or Visual Studio 2010 you know it's probably going to be like you said you know five years from now at least something to look
所以我认为它已经在 GCC 和最新版本的 Visual Studio 中了。好吧。但是，等到那些东西真正被企业采用时，我的意思是，有些公司仍然在使用 GCC 2.9。是的。或者 Visual Studio 2005。是的，没错。所以等到人们开始使用 GCC 4.5（我认为这是支持 C++ 2011 的版本）或者 Visual Studio 2010 时，正如你所说，可能至少还要五年时间。这是值得
forward in the future with our better radio equipment. Yeah, that's right. And our better C++ compilers. Yeah, definitely. All right. Well, I had a news story that is solved this week about Google hiring the inventor of Java, the guy who actually holds some of the patents there and worked for Sun, now Oracle, on creating the Java language. And they hired him to work on android which of course android runs um a java virtual machine the dalvik virtual machine their own version own implementation of it and additionally are being presently sued by oracle yeah um on in regards to some patent
期待的未来，用我们更好的无线电设备。是的，没错。还有我们更好的 C++ 编译器。是的，绝对是。好了，我这周有一个新闻，关于谷歌聘请了 Java 的发明者，那个真正拥有一些专利并曾在 Sun（现在是 Oracle）工作，参与创建 Java 语言的人。他们聘请他去开发 Android，当然 Android 运行着 Java 虚拟机，即 Dalvik 虚拟机，他们自己的版本，自己的实现。此外，他们目前正被 Oracle 起诉，关于一些专利
infringement that's alleged there and so they hired the this guy who's really key to the invention of java and there's a you know some speculation about exactly what they were thinking there. One, to obviously make the Dalvik virtual machine better, you know, get the guy who is in the know, get him there, get him working on it, make it, you know, just better. And, you know, also this guy is, you know, pretty well respected. Java is very popular, very commonly used. And it's, you know of he's kind of a star so i his name is escaping me right now but i mean basically he is able to james gosling okay so but i mean him being in google now is going to mean people are going to want to go work at google not
侵权指控。所以他们聘请了这位对 Java 发明至关重要的人，人们对他们的意图有一些猜测。第一，显然是为了让 Dalvik 虚拟机变得更好，找来那个知情的人，让他去工作，让它变得更好。而且，这个人也相当受人尊敬。Java 非常流行，使用非常广泛。他算是一位明星，所以我现在想不起他的名字了，但基本上他能够……是 James Gosling，好吧。但我的意思是，他现在在谷歌工作，意味着人们会想要去谷歌工作，不是
that they're of want of people wanting that work there any more than they already do but now they're going to recruit even more top talent to go work there and you know want to work next to to mr gosling there and you know be with this kind of i guess rock star yeah i think that maybe um someone one of the vps at google you know is getting programming language inventors a little confused with pokemon because he's trying to collect every single one of them. He's already got Guido for Python and now James Gosling. The guy who invented Go already worked at Google,
说人们想去那里工作是因为他，而是现在他们会招募更多顶尖人才去那里工作，人们想在 Gosling 先生身边工作，和这种摇滚明星在一起。是的，我想也许谷歌的某位副总裁把编程语言发明者和宝可梦搞混了，因为他正试图收集每一个。他已经有了 Python 的 Guido，现在又有了 James Gosling。发明 Go 语言的人已经在谷歌工作了，
the Go programming language. So yeah, it's kind of an interesting... So maybe they're cornering the market on new programming languages. Yeah, it's quite possible. This is going to make life difficult for us. Or maybe not. Who knows?
Go 编程语言。所以这很有趣……也许他们正在垄断新编程语言的市场。是的，很有可能。这会让我们的生活变得困难。或者也许不会。谁知道呢？
But we want to do a different programming language every two weeks. And if Google buys them all, hopefully they won't consolidate them. Hopefully they'll continue to. Maybe make a diversity. Get them working on new languages. Yeah. That would be cool. Yeah, definitely.
但我们想每两周介绍一种不同的编程语言。如果谷歌把它们都买下来，希望他们不会把它们整合在一起。希望他们能继续保持多样性。让他们去开发新语言。是的，那会很酷。是的，绝对。
Good stuff. Talking about Google. Yeah. Well, actually, one thing relating to what you were just talking about, it's interesting that patents are becoming more and more of an issue. And Google seems to be getting sued left, right, and center over different patents. They're getting sued over their search engine, which is not necessarily patent-related. But they're getting sued over this patent issue with Sun and they are in they're right now the highest bidder on Novell's um patents so basically Novell's broken
好东西。说到谷歌。是的，实际上，有一件事和你刚才说的有关，有趣的是专利正变得越来越成问题。谷歌似乎正因为各种专利被四处起诉。他们因为搜索引擎被起诉，这不一定与专利有关。但他们因为与 Sun 的专利问题被起诉，而且他们现在是 Novell 专利的最高出价者，所以基本上 Novell 已经分崩离析，
apart and they're selling you know different pieces of that of that organization and Google explicitly is out to buy the patents and from what I read on their blog they basically they don't necessarily have an interest in the specific patents they're buying. But for them, it's sort of like this cold war where everyone needs to stockpile these nuclear patents. And, you know, whoever has the most, you know, can kind of threaten boss everyone else around. And Google feels like they're getting kind of bossed around since they're a newer company. So they're trying to, you know, acquire these patents. And there really needs to be some serious patent reform i mean yeah i agree we need patents are a good thing i mean in in general but when they're improperly applied it can be disastrous and i
他们正在出售该组织的不同部分，谷歌明确表示要购买这些专利。从我在他们博客上读到的内容来看，他们并不一定对所购买的具体专利感兴趣。但对他们来说，这就像一场冷战，每个人都需要囤积这些核武器般的专利。谁拥有的最多，谁就可以威胁和支配其他人。谷歌觉得他们作为一家较新的公司正在被欺负，所以他们试图收购这些专利。确实需要进行一些严肃的专利改革。我的意思是，我同意专利在一般情况下是件好事，但当它们被不当应用时，可能会造成灾难性的后果，而且我
think this kind of getting there with computer programming and some of the stuff that they got going on in computer patents is just some of it's pretty ridiculous and it's going to cause more harm than good and um like you said i agreed that cold war analogy is fairly apt i guess that you know mutually assured destruction so if google buys up all of novell's patents then we'll find something in there to sue anybody who tries to sue them exactly it's just kind of go around and around and around and we're not lawyers at least oh no i'm not but don't take this as yeah legal advice but uh definitely i mean it's an interesting thing and and lawyers win right you know get more money to go after more people and file more suits yeah but um hopefully there's some some silver
认为在计算机编程领域，他们正在进行的一些计算机专利相关的事情有些相当荒谬，这弊大于利。正如你所说，我同意那个冷战类比相当贴切，你知道，相互保证毁灭。所以如果谷歌买下了 Novell 的所有专利，那么他们就会在里面找到一些东西来起诉任何试图起诉他们的人。没错，这就像是一个循环，我们不是律师，至少我不是，但不要把这当作法律建议。但这确实是一件有趣的事情，律师们赢了，对吧？他们得到更多的钱去起诉更多的人，提起更多的诉讼。但希望这对程序员来说能有一线希望，
lining for the programmer somewhere that world will be a better place because of all of this yeah i mean i've always been a fan of the of course you know this doesn't work in too many companies but but some of the companies have adopted a philosophy of sort of catch me if you can you know like they're on the cutting edge and uh they this is basically the premise behind uh you know commercial open source is the idea that you put something out in the open and by doing so you take a product and turn it into a standard so like open gl for example is a standard versus direct x which is a product and so google's done with this with many different technologies the g unit the google unit test framework for example that's just a framework that they could have tried to market to enterprise
世界会因为这一切变得更美好。是的，我一直是一个拥护者，当然这在很多公司行不通，但有些公司采取了一种“有本事就来抓我”的哲学，就像他们处于领先地位一样。这基本上是商业开源背后的前提，即你把东西公开，通过这样做，你把一个产品变成了一个标准。比如 OpenGL 是一个标准，而 DirectX 是一个产品。所以谷歌在许多不同的技术上都这样做过，例如 Google Unit Test 框架，那只是一个他们本可以尝试向企业
companies but now they've published it open source and so many people have jumped on it that it's become a standard. And now they are sort of in charge of that and they can kind of mold that and they can also act as an advisor for that in a commercial setting. But yeah, I mean, the patent thing, there's so many people who don't subscribe to that catch me if you can philosophy and want to sort of, you know, actually own things that they have researched for extended amount of time. Yeah, it's hard. I see both sides of it. But I mean, I think most people agree, even outside of software and technology patents, the patent system is kind of problematic right now.
销售的框架，但现在他们将其开源了，很多人都加入了进来，它变成了一个标准。现在他们某种程度上负责那个东西，他们可以塑造它，也可以在商业环境中担任顾问。但专利问题，有很多人并不认同那种“有本事就来抓我”的哲学，而是想拥有他们研究了很长时间的东西。是的，这很难。我看到了两面性。但我认为大多数人都会同意，即使在软件和技术专利之外，专利制度目前也是有问题的。
And right. A lot of issues going on there. Well, I guess at some point maybe we can have a longer discussion about this, a more intelligent, or maybe get somebody on it to talk to us a little bit more about the intricacies that lie there. Yeah, yeah, definitely. I think it's a good idea. So my previous transition failed when I said that, you know, and talking about Google, we had google hires inventor
没错。那里有很多问题。好吧，我想在某个时候也许我们可以对此进行更深入的讨论，或者找人来和我们谈谈其中的复杂性。是的，绝对。我认为这是个好主意。所以我之前的过渡失败了，当我提到谷歌时，我们有谷歌聘请了 Java 发明者，
java and google sponsoring a code jam what's that what's a code jam yeah that was between your fingers when you do a lot of coding in between like the fingernail you have sometimes the keys you know they start to scratch off and they end up kind of between your fingernail or what gets down between the keys when you're eating your sandwich and typing yeah that's right that's uh that is definitely co-gym we want to avoid that but the uh this particular co-gym is actually a programming contest and so this is uh this is quite interesting there's several um you know contests like this so for you guys who are still in college or even in high school they're starting the ACM which is the Association of Computing and Machinery is hosts collegiate programming challenge and so it starts at the starts at the I guess the regional level so the southeast United States is one region
以及谷歌赞助 Code Jam。那是什么？什么是 Code Jam？是的，那是当你做大量编码时，指甲之间有时会有按键的碎屑，你知道它们开始脱落，最终进入你的指甲缝，或者当你吃三明治打字时掉进按键里的东西。是的，没错，那绝对是 Code Jam。我们想避免这种情况，但这个特定的 Code Jam 实际上是一个编程竞赛。这很有趣，有几个这样的竞赛。所以对于那些还在上大学甚至高中的人，ACM（计算机协会）正在举办大学编程挑战赛，它从区域级别开始，比如美国东南部是一个区域，
North Africa I believe is a region basically the entire world is divided according to population and if you do well in your region you can move on to the Intercontinental Programming Challenge where they try to find the best programmers in the world at the collegiate level. There is Topcoder which is another competition for trying to test your mettle against other programmers and uh this is you know yet a third one the google code gym this one's particularly exciting it comes around once a year um there's many different puzzles um you know at all different levels and uh they uh some of the prizes um get serious i mean they have a ten thousand dollar top prize
北非我相信也是一个区域，基本上整个世界是根据人口划分的。如果你在你的区域表现出色，你可以进入洲际编程挑战赛，他们在那里试图寻找大学水平的世界最佳程序员。还有 Topcoder，这是另一个测试你与其他程序员相比实力的竞赛。这是第三个，Google Code Jam。这个特别令人兴奋，一年一次，有很多不同级别的谜题。有些奖金很丰厚，他们有 1 万美元的最高奖金，
just cash. Nice. But yeah, I mean, you could also bet that Google will be, you know, sort of interested in the people who win and is going to try to follow them, you know, throughout their career. So is this open to just regular working people or just to college students? Oh, good point. Yeah. So I believe the Google Code Jam is open to everyone. Yeah, that's right. So according to Google, if you are the code version of a ninja trying to master your grappling hook, or a chess grandmaster, or a Taoist philosopher explaining the deep truths of the world to your followers, if you're like that, but on the coding plane, you know, so I guess that extends to everybody. Nice.
纯现金。不错。但你也可以打赌，谷歌会对获胜的人感兴趣，并试图在他们的职业生涯中关注他们。那么这只对普通上班族开放，还是只对大学生开放？哦，好问题。是的，我相信 Google Code Jam 对所有人开放。是的，没错。根据谷歌的说法，如果你是试图掌握抓钩的忍者，或者是国际象棋大师，或者是向追随者解释世界深层真理的道家哲学家，如果你是那样的人，但在编码领域，我想这适用于所有人。不错。
You can participate in this. And, you know, Patrick and I have both done programming competitions in college, and I've continued on, you know, judging and writing problems and things like that. And I can tell you it's a lot of fun. It's a great way to meet some extremely talented people and also to sort of you know hone your skills and to learn you know more about programming and it's a nice slice of humble pie yeah definitely there's one person who's just awesome and amazing and we all envy you and wish we were you and you do really well at everything you do yeah you
你可以参加这个。Patrick 和我在大学里都参加过编程竞赛，我后来也继续担任评委和编写题目之类的工作。我可以告诉你，这非常有趣。这是结识一些非常有才华的人的好方法，也是磨练技能、学习更多编程知识的好方法，而且这是一种很好的谦逊教育。是的，绝对。有一个人非常棒，令人惊叹，我们都羡慕你，希望我们就是你，你在你做的每一件事上都做得很好。是的，你
probably end up eating a big slice of humble pie when you think you're ninja amazing awesome stealth skills and show up on one of these things and get smacked down by the you know 17 18 year old kid who's just a programming rock star yeah yeah definitely there's people who just have extraordinary talent and uh you know we just but i think that you know everybody regardless of you neither of us are uh are that level and uh probably many of you at home aren't best of the best but uh you know you could always improve and get better definitely definitely take it as a challenge rise to the occasion and say i'm gonna learn and get better and show them who's boss that's right yeah we might not do three on three basketball down the street. That's right. We might not do three-on-three basketball down the street,
可能最终会吃下一大块谦逊的苦头，当你认为自己是忍者般惊人、拥有超强隐身技能，结果出现在这些比赛中，却被一个 17、18 岁、只是个编程摇滚明星的孩子打败时。是的，绝对有人拥有非凡的天赋，我们只是……但我认为每个人，无论如何，我们两个都不是那个水平，你们在家里的许多人可能也不是最顶尖的，但你总是可以进步和变得更好。绝对，绝对把它当作一个挑战，迎接挑战，说我要学习并变得更好，向他们展示谁才是老大。没错，我们可能不会在街上打三对三篮球。没错，我们可能不会在街上打三对三篮球，
but we could do some coding ninja. You can go baseline, take it to the hoop with your C++ and Python and the different things that you've learned on the show. One other thing, too, is just the, I feel like a big part of it is being able to just write code quickly. I mean, that is one of those things, you know, often, you know, many of us work 40-hour-a-week jobs, and we have, you know, the luxury of spending a day kind of thinking about how we're going to tackle a problem. And often the things we work on take months, so they require, you know, an architecture.
但我们可以做一些编程忍者的事情。你可以带球过人，用你在节目中学到的 C++ 和 Python 以及各种东西冲向篮筐。还有一件事，我觉得很大一部分是能够快速编写代码。我的意思是，这是其中之一，我们很多人每周工作 40 小时，我们有奢侈的时间花一天时间思考如何解决一个问题。而且我们处理的事情通常需要几个月，所以它们需要一个架构。
But this is a unique opportunity where someone gives you 15 minutes to write something that you know you're just going to throw away in an hour or so once it's done. And just being able to consolidate your thoughts and just put them out in the code, that is just a really awesome skill to have and it's a lot of fun to execute. Yeah, definitely. I think there's a balance there, getting code done fast and getting it done right. Yeah. It's good to make sure you have both sides of that coin yeah definitely that's good so i guess uh do you have i think you have some news on facebook oh yeah so um saw the last couple days that facebook open sourced its server architecture its data center how it does so all of these big web companies serve up you know i guess millions billions of pages a day, you know, and it takes a lot of big iron workstations.
但这是一个独特的机会，有人给你 15 分钟写一些你知道完成后一小时左右就会扔掉的东西。能够整合你的想法并把它们写成代码，这真是一项非常棒的技能，执行起来非常有趣。是的，绝对。我认为这里有一个平衡，快速完成代码和正确完成代码。是的。确保硬币的两面都有是很好的。是的，绝对，那很好。所以我想，你有关于 Facebook 的新闻吗？哦，是的，过去几天看到 Facebook 开源了它的服务器架构，它的数据中心，它是如何运作的。所有这些大型网络公司每天都要服务数百万、数十亿的页面，这需要很多大型铁质工作站。
So I guess big iron is mainframes and stuff. So it's a wrong term there. But a lot of very large servers and very big data centers to do the kind of processing that they need to be able to provide the services that are, you know, they're bread and butter. And so there's a lot of black magic, you know, trade secrets that go into exactly how you do stuff because little things become a big deal. Yeah, just to put it in perspective, I have the Facebook statistics up. So that they have more than 500 million active users. So, and then it says 50% of our active users log into Facebook in any
所以我猜大型铁质是指大型机之类的东西。所以那个术语用错了。但需要很多非常大的服务器和非常大的数据中心来处理他们需要提供的服务，这些服务是他们的命脉。所以有很多黑魔法，你知道，商业秘密，关于你到底是如何做事的，因为小事情会变得很重要。是的，为了说明这一点，我查了 Facebook 的统计数据。他们有超过 5 亿活跃用户。所以，上面说 50% 的活跃用户在任何
given day so think about that in one day 250 million different people go to Facebook and do something you know different you know at least they're either gonna look at their own page which is completely different almost entirely and then you know they might do some things that are shared but for the most part they're all you know creating content looking at content of people in their neighborhood and that the magnitude of the amount of data and the amount of information that they have to yeah and different than even a Google search or serving up a static web page or you know there's a regular web blog or something.
给定的一天登录 Facebook。所以想想看，一天之内有 2.5 亿不同的人访问 Facebook 并做一些事情，至少他们会看自己的页面，这几乎完全不同，然后他们可能会做一些共享的事情，但大部分情况下，他们都在创建内容，查看邻居的内容，这种数据量和信息量，他们必须……这甚至不同于谷歌搜索或提供静态网页，或者普通的网络博客之类的。
I mean, Facebook has a lot of rights to their databases and to their things. And that's a whole different architecture and art that goes on to that. So these data centers, they have, you know, things that normally we would take for granted, like how close you are to a power generation plant. So they try to locate a lot of these next to really cheap sources of power, because it makes a big difference. So in cities with large hydroelectric dams and stuff like that, that allows them to get the energy really cheap. And even cutting unnecessary things out of their motherboards and off their process, off their, you know, server racks that aren't needed to save that last little, you know, few watts of power. It makes a big difference when you're talking, know thousands upon thousands of machines you know running and keeping them cool so they was reading they don't use air conditioning like normal they
我的意思是，Facebook 对他们的数据库和事物有很多权利。这是一种完全不同的架构和艺术。所以这些数据中心，他们有我们通常认为理所当然的事情，比如你离发电厂有多近。所以他们尽量把这些中心建在非常便宜的能源来源旁边，因为这有很大的不同。在拥有大型水电大坝之类的城市，这使他们能够以非常便宜的价格获得能源。甚至从他们的主板和服务器机架上切掉不必要的组件，以节省最后那几瓦的电力。当你谈论成千上万台机器运行时，这有很大的不同，保持它们凉爽，所以我读到他们不像普通人那样使用空调，他们
use this they spray a mist of water that evaporates and the evaporation makes the air cooler and then they blow air through that and use that to do the cooling for these data centers and it's very interesting and Facebook I guess has been talking about that they even use that heat that's generated in the server room to heat the other parts of their building during the cooler months. They don't have to run heaters and stuff. And so these server rooms can get pretty hot, all this energy going in, it can be expensive. So anything they can do to save money, to save power, which ends up leading to money to do things faster, do more with less is a good thing. And so people are, you know, kind of saying, well, why did Facebook open sources?
使用喷雾水蒸发，蒸发使空气变冷，然后他们吹空气通过那里，用它来冷却这些数据中心，这非常有趣。Facebook 似乎一直在谈论他们甚至使用服务器室产生的热量在较冷的月份加热他们建筑的其他部分。他们不需要运行加热器之类的东西。所以这些服务器室可能会变得很热，所有这些能量输入，可能会很昂贵。所以他们能做的任何节省金钱、节省电力的事情，最终导致更快地做事，用更少的资源做更多的事情，都是一件好事。所以人们在说，为什么 Facebook 要开源它？
If it's so proprietary, if it's so important to how they do things, you know, what's the incentive there to open source that? And so there's speculation abounds. Of course, one is just to give back. So a lot of these websites, you know, at least start off on open source stacks of software. So some people are trying to say, well, maybe they're, you know, just trying to put that in the hardware and say, let's open source stacks of software so some people are trying to say well maybe they're you know just trying to put that in the hardware and say let's open source this another jason pointed out earlier in his talk about patents is that if facebook can release kind of an open open book on how to do data centers and they can get other people who are small like them so i think facebook currently um is some some you know tenth the size of Google
如果它如此专有，如果它对他们的做事方式如此重要，那么开源它的动机是什么？所以猜测很多。当然，一个是回馈。所以很多这些网站至少是从开源软件栈开始的。所以有些人试图说，好吧，也许他们只是试图把它放入硬件中，说让我们开源这个。Jason 之前在他的专利谈话中指出，如果 Facebook 可以发布关于如何建立数据中心的公开书，他们可以吸引其他像他们一样的小公司，所以我认为 Facebook 目前是谷歌的十分之一，
in terms of money and earnings and stuff. I don't remember the exact number. I'm probably completely off on that. But they're not as big or as established as Google. So Google's had time to go build all of their web servers up and get everything together and have it made their way. Facebook's kind of trying to move more aggressively and doesn't have that inertia behind it
在金钱和收入方面。我不记得确切的数字。我可能完全说错了。但他们不像谷歌那样大或成熟。所以谷歌有时间去建立他们所有的网络服务器，把一切整合在一起，并以他们的方式完成。Facebook 正在试图更积极地行动，并没有那种惯性在背后
to get that stuff done. So one way they can outmaneuver the other guys, Microsoft and Google and Twitter and whoever, right, is to say, like, hey, let's open source this. Let's get people to cooperate with us. And then they, you know, become help to find the standard and they win in the end because they're helping others and then other people contribute back and give new ideas and bring more to the party. And as a group, multiple companies work together to make a bigger entity than their enemies, basically.
来完成那些事情。所以他们可以胜过其他人的方法之一，微软、谷歌、Twitter 等等，就是说，嘿，让我们开源这个。让我们让人们与我们合作。然后他们帮助定义标准，他们最终获胜，因为他们在帮助别人，然后其他人回馈并提供新想法，为聚会带来更多东西。作为一个群体，多家公司共同努力，创造一个比他们的敌人更大的实体，基本上。
Well, not their actual enemies. It's really interesting because it's sort of the inverse of what traditionally happens, which is, let's say, Linksys, for example. So Linksys wants to sell the router. They want to sell the hardware. And they'll give you the firmware updates and all the software updates for free because they want to sell this piece of equipment. And as we move more to a sort of service-oriented industry, we're going to find exactly the opposite of that, where
嗯，不是他们真正的敌人。这真的很有趣，因为它与传统发生的事情正好相反，比如 Linksys。Linksys 想卖路由器。他们想卖硬件。他们会免费给你固件更新和所有软件更新，因为他们想卖这台设备。随着我们向服务导向型行业发展，我们将发现完全相反的情况，即
the hardware and the actual infrastructure doesn't really matter. And they can give all of those secrets away for free. But what is important is the service that they're providing and the actual infrastructure doesn't really matter. And they can give all of those secrets away for free. But what is important is the service that they're providing and the user base. Yeah, it's interesting. It's a new approach. And I like to kind of open source this stuff. That's interesting. And putting that into new areas, another thing that's a little off topic, but some open source electronics that are interesting like hobby electronics there's like the Arduino or
硬件和实际基础设施并不重要。他们可以免费提供所有这些秘密。但重要的是他们提供的服务，实际基础设施并不重要。他们可以免费提供所有这些秘密。但重要的是他们提供的服务和用户群。是的，这很有趣。这是一种新方法。我喜欢这种开源这些东西的方式。这很有趣。并将其投入到新领域，另一件有点离题的事情，但一些有趣的开源电子产品，比如业余电子产品，有 Arduino 或
some other people who do kind of open embedded devices the Beagle board, there's another one, the Panda board Gumsticks I don't know if the Gumsticks is how open are they? They use Angstrom Linux. Okay, so running it but even to the point of some of these
其他做嵌入式设备的人，Beagle Board，还有另一个，Panda Board，Gumsticks。我不知道 Gumsticks 有多开放？他们使用 Angstrom Linux。好吧，所以运行它，但甚至到其中一些
like the Beagle board and the Arduino are open source, like the actual, you know, they'll give you all the stuff necessary to make your own boards if you want to. Oh, like the pin layout. The pins layout, the PCB screens, whatever. You know, I'm getting way outside of my area of expertise there. But this is a really interesting thing because in the past,
比如 Beagle Board 和 Arduino 是开源的，就像实际的，他们会给你制造你自己的板子所需的所有东西，如果你想要的话。哦，比如引脚布局。引脚布局，PCB 屏幕，等等。我正在超出我的专业领域。但这真的很有趣，因为在过去，
that's how you make it, right? So, you know, people might say, well, we'll release the open source to this, but it's not really necessarily all that valuable. But these guys are releasing everything. So if you wanted, you could we'll release the open source to this but it's not really necessarily all that valuable but these guys are releasing everything so if you wanted you could just do it the same i think they still protect some things like you can't call it an arduino if you don't have permission from them or whatever just so that the idea is being that people don't make inferior products or cut corners or do stuff wrong and then still be able to use the name but yeah they kind of release everything and make it gets better because of that you build
这就是你制造它的方式，对吧？所以人们可能会说，好吧，我们会发布这个的开源代码，但这不一定那么有价值。但这些人正在发布一切。所以如果你想，你可以……我们会发布这个的开源代码，但这不一定那么有价值，但这些人正在发布一切，所以如果你想，你可以直接做。我想他们仍然保护一些东西，比如如果你没有他们的许可，你就不能叫它 Arduino，或者其他什么，这样做的目的是人们不会制造劣质产品或偷工减料或做错事，然后仍然能够使用这个名字。但他们确实发布了一切，并因此变得更好，你建立
up a community around it and then you know it's able to be better than if you spent time and effort on your own and so it's uh plus you get goodwill um from the community at large people who say oh we like that you do this this is a good idea right and so then they kind of like you they buy it from you they support you uh even though financially it doesn't make a lot of sense because somebody else could do it and do it cheaper but they want to go to you because you did this like you did something awesome and nice right and the community is a really important word because you know really ultimately that's what facebook is all about is it's about the fact that they have this gigantic user base, this 250 million users a day. And even if the source code to Facebook, say, got leaked out,
了一个围绕它的社区，然后它能够比你自己花时间和精力做得更好。而且你从社区那里获得了善意，人们说哦，我们喜欢你这样做，这是一个好主意，对吧？所以他们有点喜欢你，他们从你这里购买，他们支持你，即使在经济上这没有多大意义，因为别人可以做它并做得更便宜，但他们想找你，因为你做了这个，你做了很棒和好的事情，对吧？社区是一个非常重要的词，因为你知道，最终这就是 Facebook 的全部意义所在，即他们拥有这个巨大的用户群，每天 2.5 亿用户。即使 Facebook 的源代码泄露了，
you wouldn't see just 10 Facebooks pop up with 500 million users. I mean, they have dominated that community. And as long as they're providing good service, there's so much momentum there. And so by open sourcing something, you can generate a lot of excitement. I mean, everyone wants to try something if it's free. And if they think that they can make it better, even more so. And so you can establish yourself as sort of like a dominant figure in, you know, technique X.
你也不会看到 10 个拥有 5 亿用户的 Facebook 冒出来。我的意思是，他们已经统治了那个社区。只要他们提供良好的服务，那里就有很大的动力。所以通过开源某些东西，你可以产生很多兴奋感。我的意思是，如果它是免费的，每个人都想尝试一下。如果他们认为他们能让它变得更好，那就更是如此。所以你可以把自己确立为某种技术 X 的主导人物。
So if you're out there and you are really into, you know, I don't know, like automatic autonomous fishing. I'm just making something up. And not the pH fishing, but actual fishing, like with a robot arm. A rod and reel. Yeah, that's right. And real water. Yeah, and not like. And real sun outside.
所以如果你在那里，你真的很喜欢，我不知道，比如自动钓鱼。我只是编造一些东西。不是网络钓鱼，而是真正的钓鱼，用机械臂。鱼竿和卷线器。是的，没错。还有真正的水。是的，不像。还有外面真正的太阳。
No grandma credit card numbers or anything. But, you know, you could open source all your autonomous robot fishing software and then you could be sort of on top of the world there. The robot fishing king. Yeah, that's right. And that could sort of carry you through that. You could make money by just being the authority in that area. Interesting, doing consulting and doing other stuff. Yeah.
没有奶奶的信用卡号码之类的。但是，你可以开源你所有的自动机器人钓鱼软件，然后你就可以成为那里的世界之巅。机器人钓鱼之王。是的，没错。那可以支撑你度过难关。你可以通过成为该领域的权威来赚钱。有趣，做咨询和做其他事情。是的。
Making appearances because of your pure awesomeness. Yeah, and then you can invent the, you know, fishing language language and then google will hire you and then we'll talk about you yeah oh man this is great we need this is good we need to get someone who knows how to fish get that ladies and gentlemen get that started um yeah that's really interesting oh before i forget we have some reviews in iTunes. That's right. Or at least one we know about. And so, oh, the username. Let's give them a shout out.
因为你的纯粹的牛逼而露面。是的，然后你可以发明钓鱼语言，然后谷歌会聘请你，然后我们会谈论你。是的，天哪，这太棒了，我们需要……这很好，我们需要找一个懂钓鱼的人，让它开始。嗯，是的，这真的很有趣。哦，在我忘记之前，我们在 iTunes 上有一些评论。没错。或者至少我们知道的一个。所以，哦，用户名。让我们给他们一个大声疾呼。
Yeah, let me see. Go ahead and open it up. Let's find it. Let's fire it up. Let's give them a thank. Somebody wrote us a nice review, and we've gotten some comments before on our blog. Now we're getting some reviews on iTunes. Thank you guys for doing that.
是的，让我看看。继续打开它。让我们找到它。让我们启动它。让我们感谢他们。有人给我们写了一个很好的评论，我们之前在博客上收到过一些评论。现在我们在 iTunes 上收到了一些评论。谢谢你们这样做。
We recently checked how many downloads did we have of our first two episodes? We had 152 episodes 152 152 that's nice but i think we can do better come on team share with your friends tell about the awesomeness that is programming throwdown yeah and uh we'll see if we can't get these numbers to go up a little to you know make this show kind of a cool thing we like we like it we enjoy it i think we're having a good time and i hope you guys are too so you know rise let us know if you like it tell us what you would like to see hear about topics languages you'd like to cover maybe you've invented a language you know let us know and uh you know we're just interested
我们最近检查了我们前两集的下载量是多少？我们有 152 集，152，152，那很好，但我认为我们可以做得更好。来吧，团队，和你的朋友分享，告诉他们 Programming Throwdown 的牛逼之处。是的，我们会看看能不能让这些数字上升一点，让这个节目成为一件很酷的事情。我们喜欢它，我们享受它，我想我们玩得很开心，我希望你们也是。所以，让我们知道如果你喜欢它，告诉我们你想看到、听到什么话题，你想涵盖的语言，也许你发明了一种语言，让我们知道，我们只是有兴趣
to hear from you guys and you know talking about open source and community you know i i guess it's a goal but we like to be able to make this kind of a community thing and you know have feedback from our fans and from you know not be just about jason and i but about the community at large it'd be kind of cool you know yeah be a part of that and if you guys have any requests for any particular languages or anything you're interested in if you want to sort of change the format or if you want to if you if you are really an expert on a particular language and uh would like to chime in and be a guest host or something like that you know uh feel free to shoot us uh shoot us an email at programmingthrowdown at gmail.com and give us
听听你们的意见。说到开源和社区，我想这是一个目标，但我们喜欢能够让这成为一种社区的事情，并从我们的粉丝那里得到反馈，不仅仅是关于 Jason 和我，而是关于整个社区。那会很酷，对吧？是的，成为其中的一部分。如果你们对任何特定的语言或你们感兴趣的任何东西有任何要求，如果你想改变格式，或者如果你是一个特定语言的专家，并且想加入并成为客座主持人，你知道，请随时给我们发电子邮件到 programmingthrowdown@gmail.com 并给我们
your feedback yeah or if you uh don't like what we say and you want to have a debate on the air so we can tell you how awesome we are and throw it down that that'd be good you know if you don't like the way jason sounds and you think we should vote him off the show no no uh no i'm just teasing we love you jason oh thanks so um okay we got it's def to d-e-f-t-e-o so uh thanks for uh thanks to the love he says love the podcast explanation oh just one explanation point i thought there was multiple ones. That was a fake out. I thought there was two. I got excited. Two explanation points. You know what?
你的反馈。是的，或者如果你不喜欢我们说的话，你想在节目中进行辩论，这样我们就可以告诉你我们有多棒，并把它扔出来。那很好，你知道，如果你不喜欢 Jason 的声音，你认为我们应该投票让他离开节目。不，不，我只是在开玩笑，我们爱你，Jason。哦，谢谢。所以，好的，我们有 d-e-f-t-e-o，所以谢谢他的爱，他说喜欢这个播客解释。哦，只有一个感叹号，我以为有多个。那是一个假动作。我以为有两个。我很兴奋。两个感叹号。你知道吗？
This is radio. There's four exclamation points. Oh, yeah. And if you see anything different, that's because it got edited between now and then. Yeah, yeah. I think he's editing it right now, actually, and making it one. Oh, no. We're going down in explanation marks.
这是电台。有四个感叹号。哦，是的。如果你看到任何不同的东西，那是因为它在那之后被编辑过了。是的，我想他现在正在编辑它，把它变成一个。哦，不。我们的感叹号要减少了。
That's right. But before he does that, he's going to make it eight. So anyways, if you guys like the podcast, definitely give us some feedback. We really appreciate it. You can post on the blog. You can post within iTunes. So that's all good stuff. All right.
没错。但在他这样做之前，他会把它变成八个。所以无论如何，如果你们喜欢这个播客，一定要给我们一些反馈。我们真的很感激。你可以在博客上发布。你可以在 iTunes 中发布。所以这些都是好东西。好了。
So tool of the bye week, Jason. Tool of the bye week. So my tool is Microsoft Dependency Walker. Is this like an old person walker? Like the thing with the tennis balls on the bottom? It does. There are tennis balls, but they're the kind of tennis balls you want to throw at your computer. And they're bricks.
所以本周工具，Jason。本周工具。所以我的工具是 Microsoft Dependency Walker。这就像一个老年人的助行器吗？就像底部有网球的那个东西？是的。有网球，但它们是你想要扔向电脑的那种网球。而且它们是砖头。
Playing tennis with bricks. Yeah, usually when you feel like playing tennis with bricks or just running your head into a brick wall that's the time when you know it's time to break out microsoft dependency walker because all right dlls are are uh you know there's the common phrase dll hell which originated from you know windows 98 and just the disaster it was back then and it's gotten a little better but not substantial so this is the magic of dependency walker if you ever run a program and it says you know error this function not found in opengl.dll or error you know direct 3d function not called something very bizarre one of these
用砖头打网球。是的，通常当你觉得想用砖头打网球或者只是把头撞在砖墙上时，那就是你知道是时候拿出 Microsoft Dependency Walker 的时候了，因为 DLL 是……你知道，有一个常见的短语“DLL 地狱”，起源于 Windows 98，那是当时的一场灾难，现在已经好了一些，但并不显著。所以这就是 Dependency Walker 的魔力，如果你曾经运行一个程序，它说错误，在 opengl.dll 中找不到此函数，或者错误，Direct 3D 函数未调用，一些非常离奇的弹出消息框，
you know message box pop-ups that that that happens before your program even starts running. This is probably because of a bad DLL on your machine, especially if this is a program that you downloaded, some program someone else made, like a game or some app that you assume has been tested by the person who you bought it from. You could assume that it's probably something on your computer. It becomes very difficult then to isolate that. So how do you know what version of OpenGL.dll you have or, you know, what version you need
在你的程序甚至开始运行之前就发生了。这很可能是因为你机器上的 DLL 损坏了，特别是如果这是一个你下载的程序，别人制作的程序，比如游戏或某些你认为已经由你购买它的人测试过的应用程序。你可以假设这很可能是你电脑上的问题。那么隔离它就变得非常困难。所以你怎么知道你有什么版本的 OpenGL.dll，或者你需要什么版本，
or where that file actually is on your computer? Because it could be anywhere in your path. So what Dependency Walker does is you give it an executable and it goes through and starts to load the executable and every time the xe asks for a dll it goes through and recursively you know puts that dll in this list and then asks the dll hey what dlls do you need and it keeps tracing down it builds this tree structure of all these dlls with the version number and the functions and if any of the functions are like mismatched or wrong it'll tell you exactly
或者那个文件实际上在你电脑上的什么地方？因为它可能在你的路径中的任何地方。所以 Dependency Walker 所做的是，你给它一个可执行文件，它会遍历并开始加载该可执行文件，每次 exe 请求一个 DLL 时，它都会递归地把那个 DLL 放入这个列表中，然后问那个 DLL，嘿，你需要什么 DLL？它会一直追踪下去，它构建了这个所有这些 DLL 的树状结构，带有版本号和函数，如果任何函数不匹配或错误，它会准确地告诉你
which ones and where they are and this becomes really important when you get those just absolutely bizarre errors at the startup of your application no you never get bizarre errors on Windows that never happens.
哪些是错误的，它们在哪里。当你启动应用程序时遇到那些绝对离奇的错误时，这变得非常重要。不，你在 Windows 上永远不会遇到离奇的错误，那永远不会发生。
Never. Yeah, really, you know, you get just the weirdest errors on every OS on startup. You know, like, let's say you're running Excel and you're editing some graph and you cause something crazy to happen. You try to edit too much data or you find some bug in Excel. It'll usually crash and it'll have some nice, you know, send this report to Microsoft, or, you know, Firefox crashes. It has this whole bug system that goes across the Internet.
永远不会。是的，真的，你知道，你在每个操作系统上启动时都会遇到最奇怪的错误。你知道，比如，假设你正在运行 Excel，你正在编辑一些图表，你导致了一些疯狂的事情发生。你尝试编辑太多数据，或者你在 Excel 中发现了一些错误。它通常会崩溃，并且会有一个很好的“发送此报告给微软”，或者 Firefox 崩溃了。它有这个跨越互联网的整个错误系统。
But if something crashes in the beginning, like on startup, yeah, you get nothing. It's like that error negative one that you get on your Apple II or whatever. I mean, it's just brutal, and it seems hopeless. Your computer has dysentery oh no all right i just i just derailed jason now so he's rolling on the floor literally when you're when your computer has serious like intestinal problems you bust out this dependency walker and that's right oh dependency walker is the peptto-Bismol. That's right.
但如果程序在启动时崩溃，那就什么都没有了。就像你在 Apple II 上看到的那个负一错误一样。我的意思是，这太残酷了，而且看起来毫无希望。你的电脑得了痢疾，哦不，好吧，我刚才把 Jason 带偏了，他现在真的在地上打滚。当你电脑出现严重的“肠道问题”时，你会拿出这个 Dependency Walker，没错，Dependency Walker 就是电脑界的健胃消食片。没错。
Oh, dependency walker is the Pepto-Bismol for your DLL needs. Yeah, it takes the dump out of DLL for sure. I think that one of the important things too, dependency walker, is letting you know when you have things installed in non-standard locations. So sometimes you'll install a game and you'll restart your computer and something will be fundamentally wrong with your entire computer. Like your Aero desktop won't work or something very bizarre will happen. It's good to run that dependency walker and realize, oh, it installed this OpenGL.dll
哦，Dependency Walker 就是你 DLL 问题的健胃消食片。没错，它确实能解决 DLL 的“排泄”问题。我认为 Dependency Walker 的另一个重要作用是，当你把东西安装在非标准位置时，它会提醒你。有时你安装一个游戏，重启电脑后，整个电脑就会出现根本性的问题。比如 Aero 桌面无法工作，或者发生一些非常奇怪的事情。运行一下 Dependency Walker，你就会发现，哦，它安装了这个 OpenGL.dll。
and now Windows itself wants to use this crazy DLL instead of the original, and it helps you sort through all those hard-to-fix problems. Yeah, it sounds like something definitely to have there. Not an everyday tool, but definitely something to have at your disposal for those really sticky, annoying situations. Yeah.
现在 Windows 本身想用这个奇怪的 DLL，而不是原来的那个，它能帮你理清所有那些难以修复的问题。是的，这听起来绝对是个必备工具。虽然不是每天都要用，但对于那些非常棘手、烦人的情况，它绝对是你手头上的利器。没错。
Good pick, good pick. Yeah, and one last part on Dependency Walker is if you're writing applications so you're on the other end of it you're a developer and you want to make an application that's not going to throw up when it runs on someone else's computer which is a good thing to have as a goal yeah i mean you don't want to spread dysentery you don't want code jam all over everybody else's computers that's right so you can run dependency walker on an exe you made, and it'll return and say, hey, this exe you made, it needs this version of OpenGL, and it needs DirectX 2011.dll. So you can infer, oh, if I give this to somebody and he hasn't updated his DirectX in a year, that it's not going to work.
好推荐，好推荐。是的，关于 Dependency Walker 的最后一点是，如果你正在编写应用程序，也就是处于另一端，你是一名开发人员，你想制作一个在别人电脑上运行时不会“呕吐”的应用程序，这是一个很好的目标。是的，我的意思是，你不想传播“痢疾”，你不想让代码在别人的电脑上到处乱喷。没错，所以你可以在你制作的 exe 文件上运行 Dependency Walker，它会返回并告诉你，嘿，你制作的这个 exe 需要这个版本的 OpenGL，还需要 DirectX 2011.dll。所以你可以推断出，哦，如果我把它给别人，而他一年没更新 DirectX 了，那它就无法运行。
And so you can really get a handle on how to deploy software using this program. Nice. So what does it do if it errors and says, you know, I need DirectX 2013? Right. So if you, you know, if you went to the, went with Patrick to the future where he bought this microphone and used DirectX 13, brought it back to the present and ran Dependency Walker on it, it would try to match up the current version of DirectX. But if there was some function that didn't exist in DirectX 2011, or if it just couldn't match them because the names weren't, they changed the name of the DLL or something like
所以你可以通过这个程序真正掌握如何部署软件。不错。那么如果它报错说，你知道，我需要 DirectX 2013，它会怎么做？对。所以如果你，你知道，如果你和 Patrick 一起去了未来，他在那里买了这台麦克风并使用了 DirectX 13，然后把它带回现在并在上面运行 Dependency Walker，它会尝试匹配当前版本的 DirectX。但如果 DirectX 2011 中不存在某些函数，或者因为它无法匹配，因为名称不对，它们更改了 DLL 的名称或者类似的情况，
that, it'll actually point at the specific function of the specific file it's missing. Interesting. So it doesn't make any recommendations, though, about how to fix it? No. It's a little lower level than that. It'll make high-level recommendations like, you're missing this DLL file, or this DLL file is missing this particular function. And from there, even without knowing what that function does, at a high level you can say,
它实际上会指出缺失的特定文件的特定函数。有趣。不过，它不会给出关于如何修复它的建议吗？不会。它的级别比那要低一些。它会给出高级建议，比如，你缺少这个 DLL 文件，或者这个 DLL 文件缺少这个特定的函数。从那里，即使不知道那个函数是做什么的，你也可以从高层面上说，
DirectX.dll is missing a function. Let me update my DirectX. Oh, that's a good point. Reinstall. Yeah, that's right. Or just download the latest Windows updates or whatever. Nicely done. All right, so what's your tool of the bye week?
DirectX.dll 缺少一个函数。让我更新一下我的 DirectX。哦，这观点不错。重新安装。是的，没错。或者只是下载最新的 Windows 更新之类的。干得漂亮。好吧，那么你本周的工具是什么？
My tool of the bye week is KeePass the bi-week is key pass spelled k-e-e pass and we'll uh put that in the show notes so is this that thing that you needed to use to uh go to the bathroom without getting detention in in elementary school or was that that's a p-pass oh that's peep okay i don't know i we didn't have to have one of those at my school. That's pretty intense. We had a, this is no joke, a fully sized like real toilet seat. And you had to carry the, you know, unused, hopefully unused toilet seat with you into the bathroom. Because there wasn't one there? No, no, there was. You had to bring your own toilet seat?
我本周的工具是 KeePass，KeePass 的拼写是 k-e-e pass，我们会把它放在节目说明里。所以这是你在小学时为了去洗手间而不被留堂需要用的那个东西吗？还是那是 p-pass？哦，那是 pee-pass，好吧，我不知道，我们学校没有那种东西。那太紧张了。我们有一个，这不是开玩笑，是一个全尺寸的、真正的马桶座圈。你必须带着那个，你知道，没用过的，希望是没用过的马桶座圈去洗手间。因为那里没有吗？不，不，有。你必须自带马桶座圈？
Oh, no, no, no. There was a toilet seat. E-Y-O-T says? You brought the... Basically, if you're walking in the hall with a toilet seat, no one questioned you. Like, it was assumed that you were going to the bathroom. So each classroom had a... Actually, only... I think just the history teachers were in on this.
哦，不，不，不。有马桶座圈。E-Y-O-T 是什么意思？你带了……基本上，如果你在走廊里拿着一个马桶座圈，没人会质疑你。就像，大家默认你要去洗手间。所以每个教室都有一个……其实，只有……我想只有历史老师参与了这件事。
But each history teacher had a toilet seat under their desk. And if you needed to use the bathroom, they... And teacher had a toilet seat under their desk and if you needed to use the bathroom they and it had a chain so you could hold it without having to touch the seat you had to be handcuffed to the toilet that's right so if you're willing to be handcuffed to the toilet seat you could avoid wetting yourself in history class wow this is this is pretty intense man i gotta think about this for a minute yeah no this is this is not i thought this was maybe going somewhere else and we were gonna lose our clean tag but okay oh no uh so yeah all right no this has nothing to do with toilets unless there's an unless here unless you are awesome
但每个历史老师的桌子底下都有一个马桶座圈。如果你需要去洗手间，他们……老师桌子底下有个马桶座圈，如果你需要去洗手间，他们……而且它有一条链子，这样你就不必接触座圈了。你得被铐在马桶上，没错。所以如果你愿意被铐在马桶座圈上，你就可以避免在历史课上尿裤子。哇，这太紧张了伙计，我得考虑一下。是的，不，这不是……我以为这会往别的地方发展，我们可能会失去“纯净”标签，但好吧，哦不，所以是的，好吧，不，这和厕所没关系，除非……除非你很棒，
and you put a passcode on your bathroom oh i've seen unauthorized usage by uh you know maybe if you live with your your family or siblings or maybe if you're still in high school or whatever you know maybe it would be a good thing to put a lock on the bathroom so you could control access to it that'd be good i've seen those really have you seen those really fancy toilets in japan like they have ones that have video games built in they have have ones that... All sorts of... Maybe there's one out there... This is circling the toilet. ...that needs a key pass. Okay. We are completely making anybody
并且你在你的洗手间上加了一个密码。哦，我见过未经授权的使用，你知道，也许如果你和你的家人或兄弟姐妹住在一起，或者也许你还在上高中什么的，你知道，也许在洗手间上加一把锁是个好主意，这样你就可以控制使用权，那会很好。我见过那些在日本非常高级的马桶，它们有内置的电子游戏，它们有……各种各样的……也许外面有一个……这话题绕着马桶转。……需要一个 key pass。好吧。我们完全让任何
who contributes to the key pass project really upset at us right now. I'm so sorry. Oh, man. All right. So key pass is an open source project. Man, we can't do these live together anymore. This is just not good.
为 key pass 项目做出贡献的人现在非常生我们的气。我很抱歉。哦，天哪。好吧。所以 key pass 是一个开源项目。伙计，我们不能再一起做这些直播了。这真的不好。
All right. Key pass project is an open source project man we can't do these live together anymore this is not good all right um key pass project is an open source project to do um being a basically a password vault so we all know come on let's be honest you don't make the best passwords ever you know um people think they do you don't and you know you're using the same one for 20 000 different things so instead of doing that you know one option right and a lot of people discourage this at work you know you're using the same one for 20,000 different things. So instead of doing that, you know, one option, right, and a lot of people discourage this at work, you know, and even at home it's generally a bad idea to write your password down. But what if you, the tradeoff there is if you write your password down, you're not going to forget it.
好吧。Key pass 项目是一个开源项目，伙计，我们不能再一起做这些直播了，这不好。好吧，嗯，Key pass 项目是一个开源项目，用来做……基本上是一个密码库。所以我们都知道，来吧，老实说，你并没有做出最好的密码，你知道，嗯，人们认为他们做到了，但你没有。而且你知道，你在 20,000 个不同的地方使用同一个密码。所以与其那样做，你知道，一个选择，对吧，很多人在工作中不鼓励这样做，你知道，你在 20,000 个不同的地方使用同一个密码。所以与其那样做，你知道，一个选择，对吧，很多人在工作中不鼓励这样做，你知道，即使在家里，把密码写下来通常也是个坏主意。但如果你这样做，权衡之处在于，如果你把密码写下来，你就不会忘记它。
So you can make it really secure so that somebody would actually have to break into your house before they'd be able to get your passwords. But this kind of gives you the best of that world of being able to have really secure passwords that have to be written down because they're so complicated and the ability to not worry about somebody breaking in and that is basically you create one really nice ultra secure password to lock up what amounts to kind of like a vault a file that's going to store all your other passwords so you make one really really good one and then you go in there and it's able to create you know accounts
所以你可以让它非常安全，这样别人必须闯入你的房子才能拿到你的密码。但这给了你两全其美的世界，既能拥有必须写下来的超安全密码，因为它们太复杂了，又能不用担心别人闯入。基本上，你创建一个非常好的超安全密码来锁定一个相当于保险库的东西，一个存储你所有其他密码的文件。所以你创建一个非常非常好的密码，然后你进去，它就能为你创建，你知道，账户
and usernames and passwords and it'll auto generate it and you can even set the rules because you know different websites have different rules you can set them to like no i i think they can even send them to like notify you that's going to expire or something so it'll have you change them so if you wanted to you know for instance gmail never has your password expire but it's probably a good idea to change your password every so often so you have key pass alert you that your password needs to be changed and it does some cool features at least I don't think it's Windows only but I'm not really sure on that but I know on Windows it'll do something really nice where like if you right-click on it once you unlock your
和用户名以及密码，它会自动生成。你甚至可以设置规则，因为你知道不同的网站有不同的规则。你可以设置它们，比如，不，我想它们甚至可以设置成提醒你密码即将过期之类的，所以它会让你更改它们。所以如果你想，你知道，例如 Gmail 从不让你的密码过期，但定期更改密码可能是一个好主意。所以你可以让 KeePass 提醒你密码需要更改。它还有一些很酷的功能，至少我不认为它只是 Windows 专用的，但我不太确定。但我知道在 Windows 上，它会做一些非常好的事情，比如如果你在解锁你的
vault and they have offer all sorts of very nice options for authentication and in multi-factor authentication to get in but um if you unlock your vault and you have your username password you can right click and copy your username on like an entry or right click and say copy your password then be able to paste it and then after a few moments it'll actually go back and overwrite your password and memory get rid of it so that you know it doesn't stay in your keyboard to be you know gotten by other other things later um so that's kind of a really nice feature. And then you can close it when you're done.
保险库后右键点击它，它们提供了各种非常好的身份验证和多因素身份验证选项来进入。但是，嗯，如果你解锁了你的保险库，并且你有你的用户名和密码，你可以右键点击并复制你的用户名，或者右键点击并说复制你的密码，然后粘贴它。几分钟后，它实际上会回去并覆盖内存中的密码，把它清除掉，这样它就不会留在你的键盘里，被以后的其他东西获取。所以这是一种非常好的功能。然后你可以在完成后关闭它。
And again, it's pretty useful. What I use it for is those websites. It's really good when you create a website that you know you're not going to remember the username and password for and it's like something really silly that you don't care if it gets broken into, but they require you to have a 10-digit password with a special character, uppercase, lowercase, numerical values, and all this stuff. And then you know, you're going to forget it. And so what you do is
再说一次，它非常有用。我用它来处理那些网站。当你创建一个你知道自己记不住用户名和密码的网站时，它真的很好用。而且它是一些非常愚蠢的东西，你不在乎它是否被黑，但它们要求你必须有一个 10 位的密码，包含特殊字符、大写字母、小写字母、数字值和所有这些东西。然后你知道，你肯定会忘记它。所以你所做的是
you can go ahead and just create an entry in here, have it auto generate it for you, and then just paste it in. And then you won't forget it, you know, just be there. And then you can back it up to, for instance, a Dropbox or to a USB stick. And my intention, I haven't done this yet, but I still plan to is to share this between my wife and I so that, you know, if so that if something were to happen to me or to her, I'd want her to be able to get into my stuff. And everybody's got their own little quirks and differences between how they handle sharing passwords between husband and wife. But certain things I would like my wife to be able to get at if something happened to me or if she needed to take care of something or if I'm on travel and she needs to help me out with something. So if she has the password and shares a file with me and we keep it up to date, then she'll be able to get at my stuff and find it. And that's a good way to keep it secure and not have to share it in the open.
你可以直接在里面创建一个条目，让它为你自动生成，然后直接粘贴进去。然后你就不会忘记它了，你知道，它就在那里。然后你可以把它备份到，例如，Dropbox 或 USB 闪存盘。我的打算，我还没做，但我仍然计划在我和我妻子之间共享它，这样，你知道，如果我或她发生了什么事，我想让她能够进入我的东西。每个人在处理夫妻间共享密码的方式上都有自己的小怪癖和差异。但如果我发生了什么事，或者她需要处理一些事情，或者我在出差而她需要帮我处理一些事情，我希望我的妻子能够获取某些东西。所以如果她有密码并与我共享一个文件，并且我们保持更新，那么她就能获取我的东西并找到它。这是一个保持安全且不必公开共享的好方法。
So how does this work? So you have your master key. Yep, your master key. And you go to a website. Let's say I go to foo.com. And foo.com says I want you to create a username and password. So what do you do from there? I go to foo.com. All right. And foo.com says, I want you to create a username and password. Yep. So what do you do from there?
那么它是如何工作的呢？所以你有你的主密钥。是的，你的主密钥。然后你去一个网站。假设我去 foo.com。然后 foo.com 说我希望你创建一个用户名和密码。那么你从那里做什么？我去 foo.com。好吧。然后 foo.com 说，我希望你创建一个用户名和密码。没错。那么你从那里做什么？
So there are ones that are more automated, but they typically tend to be integrated in with your browser, which, of course, becomes a problem if you're on multiple computers. Or, you know, if you use like me, I use a ton of different browsers just to switch it up. I don't know why. But what you do is you go there, right? And then you say, oh, I got to create a username and password. So my workflow is then I'll go startup key pass i'll type in my master password just nice and secure and no i'm not going to tell you and uh then what it does that i can right click in it or go to an option basically say create new entry tell it the website name so like you know foo.com tell it my username i want so patrick and then um what i do is I can have it generate a password for me. And I have
所以有些是更自动化的，但它们通常倾向于与你的浏览器集成，当然，如果你在多台电脑上使用，这就会成为一个问题。或者，你知道，如果你像我一样，我使用大量不同的浏览器只是为了切换一下。我不知道为什么。但你所做的是你去那里，对吧？然后你说，哦，我得创建一个用户名和密码。所以我的工作流程是，我会启动 KeePass，输入我的主密码，非常安全，不，我不会告诉你的。然后它所做的是，我可以右键点击它，或者去一个选项，基本上说创建新条目，告诉它网站名称，比如，你知道，foo.com，告诉它我想要的用户名，比如 patrick，然后，嗯，我所做的是我可以让它为我生成一个密码。我有
just default rules. It's a really nice long password that, you know, whatever. Or you can just type in your own password and then save it. And it'll remember the entry for you. So then later, instead of having to do the password recovery for this website you go to once every three years or whatever, you can just go back to KeePass and look it up. Oh, I see. So now you come back the next day and you want to log into foo so you put food comm in a key pass and hit you know recall or something yeah well it just has a list yeah it has a list of all the entries you have okay you might be able to search or you can categorize them and you know it's pretty flexible yeah you basically can just right click
默认规则。这是一个非常好的长密码，你知道，随便什么。或者你可以直接输入你自己的密码，然后保存它。它会为你记住这个条目。所以以后，你就不必为这个你每三年才去一次的网站进行密码恢复了，你可以直接回到 KeePass 并查找它。哦，我明白了。所以现在你第二天回来，想登录 foo，所以你在 KeePass 中输入 foo.com 并点击，你知道，召回之类的。是的，它只是有一个列表，是的，它有一个你拥有的所有条目的列表。好的，你也许可以搜索，或者你可以对它们进行分类，你知道，它非常灵活。是的，你基本上可以直接右键点击
on the entry and say copy username copy password or you can open it up and you know unmask the password have it show you what the password is or you know a variety of different things there it's pretty flexible i find to be very nice and it's open source so the idea is that it's been looked at by a lot of people and should be secure it's not going to steal your passwords and it's free there are other ones that you have to pay for but i just want to open source so you know hopefully people have checked this out and made sure that it's you know really nice and secure and they're not making bad assumptions or going to let your passwords leak out, especially if you're going to put all your passwords in. And I still, as much as I should trust, I don't necessarily trust it for things like my bank login and password. I tend to just try to memorize.
该条目并说复制用户名、复制密码，或者你可以打开它，你知道，取消掩码密码，让它显示密码是什么，或者，你知道，那里有各种不同的东西。它非常灵活，我觉得非常好。而且它是开源的，所以它的想法是它已经被很多人看过了，应该是安全的。它不会窃取你的密码，而且它是免费的。还有其他一些你需要付费的，但我只是想要开源的，所以你知道，希望人们已经检查过这一点，并确保它是，你知道，非常漂亮和安全，他们没有做出错误的假设，也不会让你的密码泄露，特别是如果你要把你所有的密码都放进去的话。而且我仍然，尽管我应该信任，但我并不一定信任它来处理像我的银行登录名和密码这样的事情。我倾向于只是尝试记忆。
But for a lot of other stuff that isn't as important but still is kind of important you know i think it's a good good thing to use well so are there does keypass have a browser plugin where it would like auto complete or anything like that um i don't know okay i'll check it out yeah it might have some integration the way i use it i don't maybe it would though that would be very powerful i guess it'd be interesting yeah yeah i'm not sure just guessing guessing. Throwing stuff in the dark. Maybe we should submit it on their feedback box or something. Yeah, that's right. So you said it's open source?
但对于很多其他不那么重要但仍然有点重要的事情，你知道，我认为这是一个很好的使用工具。好吧，那么 KeePass 有浏览器插件可以自动填充之类的吗？嗯，我不知道。好的，我会去看看。是的，它可能有一些集成。我使用它的方式，我不知道，也许会有，那会非常强大。我想这会很有趣。是的，是的，我不确定，只是猜测。在黑暗中摸索。也许我们应该在他们的反馈框里提交一下之类的。是的，没错。所以你说它是开源的？
It's open source, so we could contribute it. That's right. I mean, we can go in and do that. It wouldn't be bad at all. But yeah, so that's my tool of the buy week. It's KeePass. Check it out. Yeah, that sounds awesome.
它是开源的，所以我们可以贡献代码。没错。我的意思是，我们可以进去做这件事。那一点也不坏。但是的，这就是我本周的工具。它是 KeePass。去看看吧。是的，听起来棒极了。
Yeah, and it looks like there is at least a Firefox extension for KeePass. Oh, nice. Yeah, it's good stuff. Cool. All right, so time for our programming language of Dubai week. That's right. That's right. So this time we're doing Erlang. That's fun to say.
是的，看起来至少有一个 Firefox 的 KeePass 扩展。哦，不错。是的，好东西。酷。好吧，那么是我们本周编程语言的时间了。没错。没错。所以这次我们做 Erlang。这名字很有趣。
Erlang. Erlang. Oh, it should be pirates use Arlang. I think pirates just use Ar. That's a statistics language. Yeah. Pirates, well, you know, they have to divvy up all the booty, and there's probably like 200 people have to get a share.
Erlang。Erlang。哦，应该是海盗使用 Arlang。我想海盗只是用 Ar。那是一种统计语言。是的。海盗，嗯，你知道，他们必须分配所有的战利品，可能有 200 个人必须分一份。
Interesting. Interesting. Nice. Okay. I think Erlang is more from that song where everybody wants cake on their birthday. I think that's really where it was. Is that right? Is that the history of Erlang?
有趣。有趣。不错。好的。我想 Erlang 更多是来自那首每个人在生日时都想要蛋糕的歌。我想那才是它的真正来源。是这样吗？那是 Erlang 的历史吗？
I don't think so. So I think the history of Erlang is the way it goes down is I guess a lot of these things are shrouded in mystery or just forgotten. But no, no, so seriously, I guess Erlang is supposed to stand for Ericsson language. It was developed by Ericsson, the telecommunications company. And it gets its roots there in doing telecommunications type software. So think, you know, like packet switching routers and that kind of interesting fun stuff, which is, you know, very high bandwidth, very, you know, necessary for fault tolerance. You know, you're going to, you know, try to be doing tons and tons of things all at once and, you know, do it as minimal know you're gonna you know try to be doing tons and tons of things all at once and you know do it as minimal amount of hardware as you have to
我不这么认为。所以我认为 Erlang 的历史是，我想很多这些事情都被笼罩在神秘之中，或者只是被遗忘了。但不是，不是，所以说真的，我想 Erlang 应该是代表 Ericsson Language。它是由电信公司爱立信开发的。它植根于开发电信类软件。所以想想，你知道，比如分组交换路由器和那种有趣的好东西，这是，你知道，非常高带宽，非常，你知道，对容错性是必要的。你知道，你打算，你知道，尝试同时做成千上万的事情，而且，你知道，用你所拥有的最少的硬件来做，
and um so in that way kind of led to a lot of the requirements that were used to to make it what it is which is a highly concurrency oriented functional programming language um that's just recently seems to be picking up a lot of steam. I guess it's been around, without it up in front of me, I think 1999? 1986 is when it appeared. I was shocked.
嗯，所以以这种方式导致了许多用于使其成为现在的样子的要求，它是一种高度并发导向的函数式编程语言，嗯，最近似乎正在获得很多动力。我想它已经存在了，没有在我面前查，我想是 1999 年？1986 年是它出现的时候。我惊呆了。
The interesting thing... Oh, it said open source as 1998. The reason why Erlang is more popular now is because in 2006 they added multi-processing support. So basically what Erlang does now is essentially, we'll talk about this more as we start talking about the language. But in the past, it was broken up into several different, you know, when you write your program, it's broken up into several different pieces. But all these pieces just ran one at a time and sort of a
有趣的是……哦，它说 1998 年开源。Erlang 现在更受欢迎的原因是因为在 2006 年他们增加了多处理支持。所以基本上 Erlang 现在所做的是本质上，当我们开始谈论这门语言时，我们会更多地谈论这一点。但在过去，它被分成几个不同的，你知道，当你编写程序时，它被分成几个不同的部分。但所有这些部分一次只运行一个，有点像
queue like asynchronously but but just but just one at a time and in 2006 they added multi processing support where several different pieces of your code could run at the same time and that made Erlang an extremely powerful language when it came to running on these multi-core and many core machines that we have today. Interesting interesting so functional programming language we talked about C and Python so far those are both imperative languages Erlang is a functional language so what it oh we could spend forever talking about this but in short you know one or two sentences what's a functional forever talking about this but in short you know one or
队列，异步的，但只是，但只是一个接一个。在 2006 年，他们增加了多处理支持，你的代码的几个不同部分可以同时运行，这使得 Erlang 在我们今天拥有的这些多核和众核机器上运行时成为一种极其强大的语言。有趣，有趣。所以函数式编程语言，我们到目前为止谈论了 C 和 Python，它们都是命令式语言，Erlang 是一种函数式语言，所以它……哦，我们可以花永远的时间谈论这个，但简而言之，你知道，一两句话，什么是函数式编程语言？
two sentences what's a functional programming language yeah so i guess you know the simple way of of uh explaining it is um if you're familiar to c or c plus plus or python or java or many of the languages that we've discussed on the podcast before you're used to sort of the you know the i guess the commands or the programming end of it or the you know the logic and the data so the idea is that you have you know you know some global memory with you know your classes and your uh your structs and your arrays and things like that and then you have functions which um you know go through call other functions or just are in some kind of a wild true going on in your main loop. And they're acting on that data.
是的，所以我想你知道，解释它的简单方法是，嗯，如果你熟悉 C 或 C++ 或 Python 或 Java 或我们在播客中讨论过的许多语言，你习惯于某种，你知道，我猜是命令或编程端，或者你知道，逻辑和数据。所以想法是你有，你知道，你知道一些全局内存，有你的类和你的结构体和你的数组之类的东西，然后你有函数，嗯，你知道，通过调用其他函数，或者只是在你的主循环中进行某种 while true 循环。它们在作用于那些数据。
So functional programming is a very different model. In functional programming, you don't really have data just sitting out there to be accessed. But each function passes in data. So in other words, your main function gets passed in the command line arguments. That's true even of C++. But there's no global memory. That's it. That's all you get. And then you can create some things inside of that main function
所以函数式编程是一个非常不同的模型。在函数式编程中，你并没有真正的数据坐在那里等待被访问。但每个函数都会传入数据。换句话说，你的主函数会传入命令行参数。即使在 C++ 中也是如此。但没有全局内存。就是这样。这就是你得到的一切。然后你可以在那个主函数内部创建一些东西，
and pass those to other functions. But it's not like there's data just sitting out there waiting to be utilized. So that's really the thing that separates functional programming from the more data driven languages like C and Python. So, yeah, I mean, I guess it has a lot of implications for Erlang being so concurrent and, you know, a lot of the problems that creep up in traditional, you know, with quotes there that you can't see because you're listening on the radio. But, you know, the traditional languages there, you know, have problems with the data that's hanging around and you're able to access it and make changes. all over the place and controlling how and who can access stuff so that you don't end up modifying
并将它们传递给其他函数。但并不是说有数据坐在那里等待被利用。所以这确实是将函数式编程与像 C 和 Python 这样更数据驱动的语言区分开来的东西。所以，是的，我的意思是，我想这对 Erlang 如此并发有很多影响，而且，你知道，许多在传统语言中潜入的问题，你知道，带引号的，因为你在收音机里听不到，但是，你知道，那里的传统语言，你知道，在悬挂的数据方面有问题，你可以访问它并进行更改，到处都是，控制谁可以访问东西，这样你就不会最终修改
different things from different places and not and getting unintended results because you're trying to do multiple things at once right like in in c++ to use some example um let's say let's say you're making uh i don't know some kind of football game uh you know american football game and you have players running around you have a quarterback a football stadium these are all classes in your in your C++ in your architecture so you know one of the football players his position might be affected as a result of one of the other players he might get tackled or he might get bumped and that might move his position his position might also be affected by himself he might be running and that might be causing his position to change. So, you know, in C++, you can never really be sure, you know, especially in a multi-processing environment, that your position, that no one
来自不同地方的不同东西，并且因为你试图同时做多件事而得到意想不到的结果，对吧？就像在 C++ 中使用一些例子，嗯，假设，假设你正在制作，我不知道，某种足球游戏，你知道，美式足球游戏，你有球员跑来跑去，你有四分卫，足球场，这些都是你 C++ 架构中的类。所以你知道，其中一个足球运动员的位置可能会受到其他球员的影响，他可能会被擒抱，或者他可能会被撞，这可能会移动他的位置。他的位置也可能受到他自己的影响，他可能在奔跑，这可能会导致他的位置改变。所以，你知道，在 C++ 中，你永远无法真正确定，你知道，特别是在多处理环境中，你的位置，没有其他人
else is bumping you and modifying your position. You know, that information is out there for grabs. And, you know, you can, you know, you can structure C++, like you said, using mutexes and semaphores and things like that and message passing. You know, it's sort of restricted and say, look, if you want to alter my position, you have to tell me. And I'm going to actually be the one, you know, mutating the position. You can just give me hints. But ultimately, you're dealing with the low level like C and C++, you're dealing with just bits and bytes, and there's nothing stopping someone else from going in and doing whatever they want with your data.
在撞你并修改你的位置。你知道，这些信息是公开的。而且，你知道，你可以，你知道，你可以构建 C++，就像你说的，使用互斥锁和信号量之类的东西以及消息传递。你知道，它有点受限，说，看，如果你想改变我的位置，你必须告诉我。我实际上会是那个，你知道，改变位置的人。你只能给我提示。但最终，你处理的是像 C 和 C++ 这样的低级语言，你处理的只是位和字节，没有什么能阻止别人进去对你的数据做任何他们想做的事。
So Erlang, by contrast, doesn't have data just sitting out there. Everything is part of a function. It's either a parameter to a function or it was created inside of a function and as you pass data from one function to the other you actually you know capsulize the data into a message and pass that message message passing yep message passing is is what Erlang's all about so you call a function with two as a parameter. What it actually does is, you know, puts two in an envelope, sends it over to that function.
所以相比之下，Erlang 没有数据坐在那里。一切都是函数的一部分。它要么是函数的参数，要么是在函数内部创建的，当你把数据从一个函数传递到另一个函数时，你实际上，你知道，把数据封装成一个消息并传递那个消息。消息传递，没错，消息传递就是 Erlang 的全部。所以你用 2 作为参数调用一个函数。它实际上所做的是，你知道，把 2 放在一个信封里，发送给那个函数。
An actual envelope? That's right, an actual envelope. Actually, what it does is it sends the number two. So they're the people still sending mail in the post office. That's right. It sends a number two with a toilet seat attached to his wrist over to your function. Too much potty humor.
一个真正的信封？没错，一个真正的信封。实际上，它所做的是发送数字 2。所以他们是还在邮局寄信的人。没错。它发送一个数字 2，手腕上系着一个马桶座圈，传给你的函数。太多的厕所幽默了。
Oh, no. Where that function can then be waiting for him. So this is also called the actor model. So do you want to try and give that a shot? So the actor model, right? There's all sorts of ways to deal with concurrency and what amounts to shared state. So if you try to, and Jason was trying to get at this
哦，不。那个函数可以在那里等着他。所以这也称为 Actor 模型。所以你想试着尝试一下吗？所以 Actor 模型，对吧？有各种各样的方法来处理并发和相当于共享状态的东西。所以如果你尝试，Jason 试图通过
with the description of the football players, but anytime you try to share state between multiple processes that need to both read and modify. So one way is to deal, and you learn about this in textbooks and stuff, but producer-consumer. So if you've got somebody producing something
对足球运动员的描述来达到这一点，但每当你试图在需要读取和修改的多个进程之间共享状态时。所以一种方法是处理，你在教科书之类的东西里学到这个，但生产者-消费者。所以如果你有某人在生产东西，
and only one other person consuming it, is happy or at least you know straightforward but when you end up with multiple producers and multiple consumers and you know consumers can also produce and producers can also consume things get you know more hairy and uh it becomes a little harder to deal with that shared state and the more shared state you have the more chance you have to mess something up and not be careful enough and so what the actor model says is instead of allowing shared state we're basically going to forbid it and that's going to cause some interesting implications both good and bad in that if you don't share state shared in state is really fast this is basically you just access memory like it's yours and everybody does the same and so that's really fast but it's dangerous so what the actor model says if let's get rid of that and let's
而只有一个其他人消费它，是快乐的，或者至少你知道是直接的，但当你最终有多个生产者和多个消费者时，你知道消费者也可以生产，生产者也可以消费，事情变得，你知道，更棘手，而且处理那种共享状态变得有点困难，你拥有的共享状态越多，你搞砸某事且不够小心的机会就越多。所以 Actor 模型说的是，与其允许共享状态，我们基本上要禁止它，这会导致一些有趣的影响，有好有坏，因为如果你不共享状态，共享状态真的很快，这基本上你只是像访问你自己的内存一样访问它，每个人都做同样的事情，所以这真的很快，但它很危险。所以 Actor 模型说，让我们摆脱它，让我们
basically say the only way to talk to another piece of code is through a mailbox like you were talking about and sending a message to it and it can determine when it wants to talk about that message how it wants to handle it and then what it wants to do and so actors you know basically boil down to really simply, they're able to receive messages, handle the responses locally, generate other messages, generate other actors. And then that's kind of pretty much it. They're not really affecting state, at least not a shared state.
基本上说，与另一段代码交谈的唯一方法是通过一个邮箱，就像你刚才说的，发送一个消息给它，它可以决定什么时候想谈论那个消息，想怎么处理它，然后想做什么。所以 Actor，你知道，基本上归结为非常简单，它们能够接收消息，在本地处理响应，生成其他消息，生成其他 Actor。然后这就差不多了。它们并没有真正影响状态，至少不是共享状态。
And so you're able to kind of have, you need a little more careful planning, but you're able to worry less about the multi-processing, multiple threads, concurrent states of your stuff because you've kind of encapsulated in this way and very much defined the interactions in a way that, if you can get your stuff to fit that paradigm, kind of eliminate the worry about having a lot of the issues that are common with other ways of doing concurrent programming. Yeah, yeah, definitely. I mean, sometimes we think as people have been doing a lot of programming in C and C++, you'll kind of have this thought experiment where you'll say to yourself, you know, life would be so easy if all of my classes were just, you know, a map of strings to, you know, different data. So in other words, if my
所以你能够有点，你需要更仔细的计划，但你能够少担心多处理、多线程、你的东西的并发状态，因为你已经以这种方式封装了它，并且非常明确地定义了交互方式，如果你能让你的东西符合那个范式，某种程度上消除了对并发编程中常见的许多问题的担忧。是的，是的，绝对。我的意思是，有时我们认为作为在 C 和 C++ 中做了大量编程的人，你会有一种思想实验，你会对自己说，你知道，如果我所有的类都只是，你知道，字符串到，你知道，不同数据的映射，生活会变得如此简单。所以换句话说，如果我的
class, if I could actually get at the different members of the class, if I could say instead of saying my class dot x equals 3, my class dot y equals 4, if I could just say like everything in my class is 3 or both things are 3. If you could do things on like a programmatic perspective. And so Python kind of does that in the sense that like classes are really dictionaries in Python. And so it kind of is an extrapolation of that thought experiment. So going back to Erlang, you know, it's sort of the idea where, you know, in C++, we have all these different classes, and the classes are good at, you know, representing
类，如果我真的能获取类的不同成员，如果我能说，而不是说我的类点 x 等于 3，我的类点 y 等于 4，如果我能说就像我类中的一切都是 3，或者两件事都是 3。如果你能从编程的角度做事情。所以 Python 在某种意义上做到了这一点，比如类在 Python 中实际上是字典。所以它有点像那个思想实验的推论。所以回到 Erlang，你知道，这有点像那种想法，你知道，在 C++ 中，我们有所有这些不同的类，而类擅长，你知道，表示
different data. So, you know, my football player class has my football player's location. And that's very modular in the sense that the football class only has the football's location. It doesn't have the player's locations in it as well. So that keeps it very compartmentalized. But the logic can C++ really let you go wild with the logic or in a lot of these imperative languages. Like you could have the football player movement in the football class because you just have access to all this data. So Erlang is sort of, you know, sort of taking the other approach, taking it all the way to the extreme where it's like, what if everyone had their own data and their own logic and operated independently? You know, what does that mean?
不同的数据。所以，你知道，我的足球运动员类有我的足球运动员的位置。这在某种意义上是非常模块化的，因为足球类只有足球的位置。它里面也没有球员的位置。所以这保持了非常区隔化。但逻辑在 C++ 中真的可以让你在逻辑上疯狂，或者在许多这些命令式语言中。就像你可以在足球类中有足球运动员的移动，因为你只是有权访问所有这些数据。所以 Erlang 有点，你知道，有点采取了另一种方法，把它推向了极端，就像，如果每个人都有自己的数据和自己的逻辑并独立运作会怎样？你知道，那意味着什么？
You know, if we extrapolate that, if we take that all the way to the extreme, you know, how does that change our way of thinking? And how does that change the kind of programs we write? Yeah, I think it's going to become more and more important to have these alternative tools in the toolbox as we move to a more multi-processor future. Right. That's an excellent point. I mean, a big problem right now is being able to do concurrent programming, being able to run two things at the same time. And it's because the logic can so easily get conflated. You know, if the football is modifying the football player's positions and they're modifying their own positions, now you have, as Patrick mentioned mentioned a race condition where you have two things modifying the same
你知道，如果我们推断这一点，如果我们把它推向极端，你知道，这如何改变我们的思维方式？这如何改变我们编写的程序类型？是的，我认为随着我们走向一个更加多处理器的未来，在工具箱中拥有这些替代工具将变得越来越重要。没错。这是一个极好的观点。我的意思是，现在的一个大问题是能够进行并发编程，能够同时运行两件事。这是因为逻辑很容易混淆。你知道，如果足球在修改足球运动员的位置，而他们也在修改自己的位置，现在你有了，正如 Patrick 提到的，竞争条件，你有两件事在修改相同
data at the same time and that causes very unpredictable results. I mean you might be assuming that your position isn't changing in this one function where you calculate something based on position and all of a sudden in the middle of that function it changes and that causes your program to act in a way that you didn't expect and causes crashes and things like that. So rather than have to sort of dwell on these things and try and compartmentalize everything yourself and possibly screw it up, you know, we can use something like Erlang where it's a little bit more strict on the logic and sort of you know forces you to think a certain way so forcing you to think this different way uh we uh look for some links for you guys for learning erlang so uh we found this uh awesome awesome website it's learn you some erlang for
数据在同一时间，这会导致非常不可预测的结果。我的意思是，你可能假设你的位置在这个函数中没有改变，你在那里根据位置计算某些东西，突然在那个函数的中间它改变了，这导致你的程序以你没有预料到的方式运行，并导致崩溃之类的东西。所以与其不得不去纠结这些事情并尝试自己把一切都区隔化，并可能搞砸它，你知道，我们可以使用像 Erlang 这样的东西，它在逻辑上更严格一点，并且某种程度上，你知道，强迫你以某种方式思考。所以强迫你以这种不同的方式思考，我们，我们为你们找了一些学习 Erlang 的链接，所以，我们发现了这个，很棒的网站，它是 Learn You Some Erlang for
great good that's right it's learn you some erlang.com is the is the domain name how do you how do you like their little mascot there the logo it was pretty epic yeah you guys should definitely check out the uh the front page of that i think it's a it's a squid who's using what eight eight different computers at the same time or something oh it's also reading the book about itself. Oh, that's awesome. You know, if he was on the cover of the book, it could be, you know, recursive, but it's not. No, I guess he's just reading about Erlang. Yeah, but one of the last,
Great Good，没错，它是 learnyousomeerlang.com 是域名。你觉得他们的那个小吉祥物怎么样，那个标志？它非常史诗，是的，你们绝对应该去看看那个主页，我想那是一只正在使用什么，八个不同的电脑同时，或者类似的东西。哦，它还在读关于它自己的书。哦，那太棒了。你知道，如果他在书的封面上，它可能是，你知道，递归的，但它不是。不，我想他只是在读关于 Erlang 的书。是的，但最后一点，
one of the thing about Erlang. Oh, sorry. Yep, go ahead. Is, so, you know, you have these different objects. And one thing that, you know, we didn't completely, you know, cement this idea, but because, you know, we've separated the logic and we've separated the data into all these different objects, they're all able to run at the same time. And that's really what gives Erlang the
关于 Erlang 的一件事。哦，抱歉。是的，继续。是，所以，你知道，你有这些不同的对象。而且有一件事，你知道，我们没有完全，你知道，巩固这个想法，但因为，你知道，我们已经分离了逻辑，我们已经把数据分离到了所有这些不同的对象中，它们都能同时运行。而这正是赋予 Erlang
concurrency. You know, the football player is able to update his position and do his AI and his calculations and whatever. And the football is able to do the projectile motion as it's being thrown independently without you as a programmer saying, all right, you guys can both run at the same time. The system does that for you. It automatically knows what things can run at the same time and it runs them all at the same time. That's what gives Erlang such a great performance in this multi-core world yeah so um we talk about libraries um the I guess the standard library equivalent for Erlang is called the OTP so sometimes you'll see this even if you go look to download Erlang it'll be the Erlang
并发性的东西。你知道，足球运动员能够更新他的位置并做他的 AI 和他的计算之类的。而足球能够在它被投掷时独立地做抛体运动，而不需要你作为程序员说，好吧，你们两个可以同时运行。系统为你做了这件事。它自动知道哪些东西可以同时运行，并且它让它们全部同时运行。这就是赋予 Erlang 在这个多核世界中如此出色性能的原因。是的，所以，嗯，我们谈论库，嗯，我想 Erlang 的标准库等价物被称为 OTP，所以有时你会看到这个，即使你去下载 Erlang，它也会是 Erlang
and like Erlang slash OTP there's something in what OTP stands for is open telecom platform and that's the open source library that includes a lot of the common things you'd want to do and want to use. And so that's kind of like the included part, the batteries, as it were, for, like we talked about last week, for Erlang, they give it, able to do stuff more than just the basic necessities. Do people use Erlang for stuff besides just telecommunications? Yeah, so I think Erlang is used in CouchDB, right? Yeah, yeah. The NoSQL database.
和像 Erlang / OTP，有一些东西，OTP 代表 Open Telecom Platform，那是开源库，包括许多你想做和想用的常见东西。所以这有点像包含的部分，电池，正如他们所说，对于，就像我们上周谈到的，对于 Erlang，他们给它，能够做不仅仅是基本必需品的事情。人们除了电信之外还用 Erlang 做别的事情吗？是的，所以我认为 Erlang 被用于 CouchDB，对吧？是的，是的。那个 NoSQL 数据库。
I believe it's also used in Wings3D, which is a 3D modeling tool. Yeah. Do you have any? Yeah, RabbitMQ, which is an implementation of the AMQP gonna say amqp the um protocol for message passing so right there getting back to its telecom roots but able to do really fast really reliable fault tolerant um message passing so amqp is that i get the order right yeah you did yeah so um it's an implementation of that so um it's used and this will parlay into the next where it's used but um able to do really high numbers of message passing and routing and they use this we've talked about a couple times with the high
我相信它也用于Wings3D，这是一个3D建模工具。是的。你有用过吗？是的，RabbitMQ，它是AMQP协议的一种实现，用于消息传递。所以这又回到了它的电信根源，但能够实现非常快速、非常可靠、容错的消息传递。所以AMQP是这样的，我没记错顺序吧？是的，你没记错。所以它是该协议的一种实现，它被用于——这会引出下一个话题——它能够处理极高数量的消息传递和路由。我们已经讨论过几次了，高
frequency trading guys and finance guys use that and uh that they we talked was it last time about the guy who stole code from goldman yeah that's right actually stole erlang code is the thing there i guess alleged right i don't know what the result of that is. I think he went to jail, so I think he's convicted. Oh, he went to jail. Yeah, we did say that. So convicted. So yeah, so that was involving Erlang code because that's part of their high-frequency trading stuff.
频交易人员和金融人员都在使用它。我们上次是不是谈到了那个从高盛窃取代码的人？是的，没错，实际上窃取的是Erlang代码，我想大概是涉嫌窃取吧，我不知道结果如何。我想他坐牢了，所以我认为他被定罪了。哦，他坐牢了。是的，我们确实说过。所以被定罪了。所以是的，这涉及Erlang代码，因为那是他们高频交易系统的一部分。
So yeah, I mean, it's used more than just telecom stuff. So the Goldman Sachs stuff, the 3D modeling, the document store database. I mean, those are kind of things that are a little bit different than just what you would think is message routing. It's also used used by and i don't have it on here right in front of me but the 2600 hertz project does some voice over ip stuff so think like skype replacement slash if you don't know asterisk is which is an open pbx um so kind of doing oh and this gets beyond what i understand but you, doing telecommunications,
所以是的，我的意思是，它的用途不仅仅是电信领域。高盛的案例、3D建模、文档存储数据库，这些都与你通常认为的消息路由有些不同。它还被——我手头没有具体资料——2600赫兹项目（2600 Hertz project）使用，做一些VoIP相关的东西，可以把它想成是Skype的替代品，或者如果你不知道Asterisk是什么，它是一个开源PBX。所以这超出了我的理解范围，但你们在做电信，
voice stuff for, you know, enterprise stuff, but doing open source and free and able to give people the ability to kind of control their own telephone system. And so they use it, which fits in with it, you know, nice telecommunications background. Yeah, and so this actually, you know, the bigger, the more broad point here is that
语音相关的东西，你知道，企业级应用，但通过开源和免费的方式，让人们能够控制他们自己的电话系统。所以他们使用它，这与它良好的电信背景非常契合。是的，所以这实际上，你知道，这里更广泛的观点是，
in the end, you can do just about anything in any language and if your frustration tolerance is high enough yeah that's true and Erlang is no doubt no no exception if you know if you go on the Wikipedia site for Erlang or you start reading the tutorials you will realize that Erlang is vast or any functional language prolog, lisp, etc. is vastly different from you know C, C++ and the imperative languages that you may be used to and you know it might seem like things are impossible you know how can you how can you write a serious large-scale app without global data you know it sounds like an impossible thing to possible task but um you would be amazed that uh that all it takes is just a shift in in paradigm and a shift in thinking and um and you
最终，你可以在任何语言中做任何事情，只要你的挫败感承受能力足够高。是的，那是真的。Erlang也不例外。如果你去Erlang的维基百科页面，或者开始阅读教程，你会意识到Erlang，或者任何函数式语言，如Prolog、Lisp等，与你可能习惯的C、C++和命令式语言有很大不同。你可能会觉得有些事情是不可能的，你知道，没有全局数据怎么能写出一个严肃的大型应用呢？这听起来像是一项不可能完成的任务，但你会惊讶地发现，所需要的只是思维范式的转变，而你
can do anything in in erlang or any of these languages and we're big proponents of that i mean part of what we're doing here is try to get people to embrace that alternative ways of thinking even if you don't end up using erlang in your day-to-day job if you go out and play with it on the weekend the evenings and you know find this brain twisting stuff and make it through it you're going to learn some new ways to look at problems and maybe it will apply even you know in using C and C++ maybe you'll look at a new way to solve a problem that you've been working on or something that was hard to tackle and now you got kind of a way to do it so here's my chance to sort of grill you you're in the hot seat no no no no i was trying to avoid this all all podcast long so what was erlang first programmed in i mean now i'm pretty sure it's in c or something but what was it in
可以在Erlang或任何这些语言中做任何事情。我们是这种理念的坚定支持者。我的意思是，我们在这里所做的一部分工作是试图让人们拥抱这种替代性的思维方式。即使你最终没有在日常工作中用到Erlang，如果你在周末或晚上去尝试一下，发现这些烧脑的东西并坚持下来，你将会学到看待问题的新方法。也许它甚至可以应用在你使用C和C++的时候，也许你会找到一种新的方法来解决你一直在处理的问题，或者以前难以解决的问题，现在你有了一种方法。现在是我拷问你的机会了，你现在处于风口浪尖。不，不，不，我整个播客都在试图避免这个。那么Erlang最初是用什么编程的？我的意思是，现在我非常确定它是用C或类似语言编写的，但它最初是用什么编写的？
in the beginning so 19 is this 1986 right. Programming history. So is it something weird? It's another functional language. Prologue? You got it. Erlang was originally implemented in Prologue, which is... Interesting. Yeah, which is short for Prologic, I believe, right? Or actually...
在最初的时候，是1986年对吧？编程历史。所以它是某种奇怪的东西吗？它是另一种函数式语言。Prolog？你说对了。Erlang最初是用Prolog实现的，它是……有趣。是的，我相信它是Prolog的缩写，对吧？或者实际上……
Well, it's not much shorter than... I think it's... Let me see here. Prologue is short for uh i think it is prologue all right well he looks that up that that's interesting so that that's something we haven't really talked about that you know if you're going to write a language you got to write it in something else yeah either you know i guess assembly because you can write a machine code you know directly if you're at a high frustration tolerance and really want to take a long time.
嗯，它并不比……我想它是……让我看看。Prolog是……的缩写。我想它是Prolog。好吧，在他查找的时候，这很有趣。这是我们还没有真正讨论过的事情，你知道，如果你要编写一种语言，你必须用另一种语言来编写它。是的，要么是汇编，因为如果你有很高的挫败感并且真的想花很长时间，你可以直接编写机器码。
But yeah, so you write it. Some languages end up what's called bootstrapping. So, you know, C wasn't first written in C, but then eventually they got to the point where you could write the C compilers in C itself and bootstrap it. But, oh, we also didn't talk about the fact that Erlang runs in a virtual machine.
但是是的，所以你编写它。有些语言最终会进行所谓的“自举”（bootstrapping）。所以，你知道，C语言最初不是用C编写的，但最终他们达到了可以编写C编译器本身并进行自举的地步。但是，哦，我们也没有讨论Erlang运行在虚拟机上的事实。
Oh, yeah. Not directly on the hardware. So that's two virtual machine programming languages in a row. All right. Did you figure it out? Well, apparently prologue doesn't stand for anything. Oh, fail.
哦，是的。不是直接在硬件上运行。所以这是连续两种虚拟机编程语言。好了，你查到了吗？嗯，显然Prolog并不代表任何东西。哦，失败了。
Jason, you're getting closer to being voted off. Oh, no. You put me in the hot seat and then you failed. I know. That's a... You just turned the tables. Yeah. Now you have a chance to, like, double dare. You can double hot seat. Oh, no. You put me in the hot seat, and then you failed. I know. Just turn the tables. Yeah, now you have a chance to double dare. You can double hot seat.
Jason，你离被投票出局越来越近了。哦，不。你把我推到风口浪尖，然后你自己失败了。我知道。这是一个……你刚刚扭转了局面。是的。现在你有机会进行“双重挑战”。你可以进行双重拷问。哦，不。你把我推到风口浪尖，然后你自己失败了。我知道。只是扭转了局面。是的，现在你有机会进行双重挑战。你可以进行双重拷问。
Oh, no. I don't think I'll be that mean. Can I take the high road? You can. You can take the high road. I'm going to take the high road. I choose that. For 100.
哦，不。我不认为我会那么刻薄。我可以选择高尚的做法吗？你可以。你可以选择高尚的做法。我要选择高尚的做法。我选择那个。为了100分。
But yeah, so Erlang is implemented in Prolog, which is another functional language. And Prolog is somewhat is another functional language. Prolog is somewhat similar to Erlang, but it doesn't have a lot of the ease of use. I feel like Prolog is very difficult to get your head around. I did a lot of Prolog in university, so we'll definitely make a show out of that.
但是是的，Erlang是用Prolog实现的，这是另一种函数式语言。Prolog在某种程度上与Erlang相似，但它没有那么容易使用。我觉得Prolog非常难理解。我在大学里做了很多Prolog，所以我们肯定会专门做一期节目来讨论它。
Okay, all right. Your future? Erlang definitely, in the same way as sort of Python makes your life easier as a developer of C or C++, Erlang definitely makes your life easier if you're a prologue developer. Interesting. Very good. All right, well, is that all we got for this week? I think so.
好的，好的。你的未来？Erlang绝对是，就像Python让C或C++开发者的生活更轻松一样，如果你是一个Prolog开发者，Erlang绝对会让你的生活更轻松。有趣。非常好。好了，这就是我们这周的所有内容了吗？我想是的。
I think that's it. Just bye week? All right, I don't think we have picked for this week? I think so. I think that's it. I think we wrapped up this week. All right, I don't think we have picked what we're going to cover next. No. So opportunity for you to write in and tell us what you'd like to hear. That's right. And influence the future. If you have a favorite, you know, we have a list of languages that we want to explore.
我想就是这样。只是双周节目？好吧，我不认为我们已经选好了这周要讨论的内容？我想是的。我想就是这样。我想我们这周结束了。好吧，我不认为我们已经选好了接下来要涵盖的内容。没有。所以这是一个让你写信告诉我们你想听什么的机会。没错。并影响未来。如果你有最喜欢的，你知道，我们有一个想要探索的语言列表。
But if you have a particular language you're interested in and we haven't covered it yet, we can easily move it to the front of the queue. Yep. So definitely give us any feedback, any info. Rate us on iTunes if you like the podcast. Rate us if it's good. If it's not, just send us an email and wait until we make it better and then rate us. That's right.
但如果你对某种特定的语言感兴趣，而我们还没有涵盖它，我们可以很容易地把它移到队列的最前面。是的。所以一定要给我们任何反馈，任何信息。如果你喜欢这个播客，请在iTunes上给我们评分。如果它很好，请给我们评分。如果不好，就给我们发邮件，等我们改进后再给我们评分。没错。
Definitely subscribe so you can get the latest episodes and stay up to date and all that. All right. If that's it, I guess we'll sign off. Yeah, this is Jason Gauci signing off. And this is Patrick Wheeler. Until next Bi-Week, that'll be it. See you later, guys. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot.
一定要订阅，这样你就可以获得最新的剧集并保持更新等等。好了，如果就是这样，我想我们要签退了。是的，我是Jason Gauci，准备签退。我是Patrick Wheeler。直到下一个双周节目，就这样。再见，伙计们。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。
Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，进行重混、改编，但你必须注明我和Patrick的署名，并以相同方式共享。目前这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。